ام
اظهرت صور خاصه حصلت عليها الجزيره فريق
اغتيال الصحفي السعودي جمال خاشقجي وهو
ينقل بقياده ماهر المطرب اكياس وحقائب
من مقر القنصليه السعوديه في اسطنبول الى
بيت القنصل يعتقد انها تحوي اجزاء من جثه
خارجي الذي تم تصفيته تصويته في الثاني من
اكتوبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا كان هذا خبر حلقتنا
نناقش ما وراء هذا الخبر ما اهميه هذه
المعطيات التي وثقتها الصور التي تظهر
فريق الاغتيال وهو ينقل اكياس وحقائب
يعتقد ان تحوي اجزاء مقطعه من جثه
وكيف ستتعامل التحقيقات والمواقف
الاقليميه والدوليه مع هذه المعطيات في ظل
الاصوات الداعي للكشف عن الحقيقه كامله في
هذه القضيه
[موسيقى]
كما لا تسقط بالتقادم
تحتفظ جريمه اغتيال الصحفي السعودي جمال
خاشقجي بقدره على البوح كل حين بملامح
جديده لبشاعتها لترد عمليا على من يراهن
على عامل الزمن لطيفه وابقائها حديثه
الحقائب والاكياس وتحقيق العدل في محاسبه
مختلف فيها ذاك ما تقوله صور خاصه حصلت
عليها الجزيره تظهر فريق الاغتيال بكره
ماهر المطرب وهو ينقل اكياس يعتقد انها
تحتوي على اجزاء جثه خاشقجي ينقلها من مقر
القنصليه السعوديه الى بيت القنصل القريب
في اسطنبول صور تستكمل المشهد وتذكر مختلف
الاطراف بمسؤولياتها الاخلاقيه والقانونيه
اتجاه الجرم الذي وقع نبدا بتقرير حسين
اكياس الحقيقه المره صور جديده من منزل
القنصل السعودي في اسطنبول تؤكد الصور ما
بات معروفا ان جثه جمال خاشقجي المفقوده
حتى الان تم توقيعها خمس حقائب كبيره كيس
انا خرجت من القنصليه الى منزل القنصل
الذي يبعد ثلاثمائه متر فقط التوقيت في
الساعه الثالثه بعد الظهر اي بعد ساعتين
من دخول خشي ونقلها ثلاثه اشخاص ماهر
المطرب قائد فريق الاغتيال واد عار الحرب
سائق السياره السوداء التابعه للقنصليه
السعوديه وصرح الطبيب مسؤول عمليه التقطيع
لكن ما الجديد فيها بجانب مسؤوليه هؤلاء
الثلاثه في الجريمه سؤال قد يتبادر
لكثيرين بعد ثلاثه اشهر من وقوعها
واحده من المسائل التي يعيد المقطع طرحها
هي موضوع البؤر التي القيت فيها الجثه في
منزل القنصل ما ليعيد التذكير ب رفض
السلطات السعوديه طالب السلطات التركيه
تفتيش البؤر في ظل انعدام ايه معلومه تؤكد
اخراج الجثه من منزل القنصل تتزامن
التسجيلات مع نشر كتاب قبل يومين ثلاثه
صحفيين من صحيفه صباح التركيه
عنوان الكتاب فضائع الدبلوماسيه الاسرار
المظلمه لقتل
وتدور استنتاجات الصحفيين على ثلاثه امور
رئيسيه
اولها النقاش الذي دار بين المطرب والطبيب
والحرب حول الاليه التي يتم التصرف فيها
مع جمال في حال رفض الاستجابه لهم وانتهى
النقاش بقتله و تقطيعه ثانيهما ان الجثه
اختفت في منزل القنصل السعودي محمد
العتيبي الذي كان لديه علم بالعمليه رغم
ان فيه المتكرر والثالثه وهو ما يبدو
جديدا في السياق انه لا صحه لوجود الم
تعاون المحلي الذي زعمته الرياض ثم رفضت
الكشف عنه على ان الكتاب يشير استنادا الى
مصادره ان التسجيلات الطبيعي اقنعت مديره
وكاله المخابرات الامريكيه جينا سبل ان
عمليه قتل فتى كانت بيته و مخططا لها الا
ان ما يكشف الكتاب مما لم يعرف سابقا هو
مشروع جيش النحل مشروع اه خشي الاحتواء
المشرقين السعوديين والناشطين ولمواجهه
الدباب الالكتروني السعودي سياق القضيه لا
يبدو انه اخذ في الاول لان القضيه لم تقل
كلمتها الاخيره تركيا تعتقد ان الحقيقه
منقوصه في ظل عدم التجاوب السعودي ورهان
الرياض على نسيان القضيه بمرور الزمن
خصوصا مع الانباء التي تشير الى ان فريق
الاغتيال يعيش حرا مرفهه وان كان متواريا
عن الانظار
اجراءات دفعت انقره على لسان وزير العدل
عبد الحميد غول الى القول ان تركيا ستتابع
القضيه الى النهايه و انها ستلجا الى كل
الاليات الدوليه الممكنه بما فيها الامم
المتحده
فالجريمه الديبلوماسيه والقضيه انسانيه
بامتياز
وضع حلقتنا اليوم مناقشه مع ضيفينا في
الاستوديو الدكتور حسن استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في الجامعه الاردنيه ومن واشنطن
باور الباحث في شؤون الخليج والشرق الاوسط
وابدا بضيفي في الاستوديو دكتور حسن براري
ما الجديد الذي اضافته هذه الصور لاسيما
ونحن ما زلنا بعيدين عن الادله الماديه
يعني لا يوجد لا يوجد قطعه من الجثه هذه
مجرد صوره ايضا الصور السابقه هل اضافه
جديده يعني بمجملها هي يمكن النظر اليها
باعتبارها شواهد جديده على هذه القضيه لم
نرى هذه المشاهد من قبل وهي تعكس ثلاث
قضايا يعني اه اه المحوريه الاولى صدقيه
الروايه التركيه على اعتبار ان كل
التسريبات التي جاءت فيها منذ البدايه
لهذا اليوم هي الان يعني اه اه الت اخذ
المصداقيه الكامله عند المشاهد بشكل عام
وايضا عند الدوله صاحبه الشان اه ثانيا اه
تكشف مساله في غايه الاهميه ان الجريمه
التي ارتكبت بحق الصحفي كانت مبيته بمعنى
ان النظريه التي حاولت السعوديه ان تقول
تقول يعني وتسوقها بان ما جرى هو بمحض
الصدفه وبناءا على ربما يعني حيثيات اثناء
الحديث مع شتى هي تسقط على اعتبار ان كل
كل شيء كان معدا سابقا وهذا ايضا يضيف
المصداقيه للروايه التركيه والشيء الثالث
الذي يكشف انا بتقديري الضعف الدبلوماسيه
السعوديه عن لغايه هذه اللحظه عن تقديم
الروايه المتكامله ل حقيقه ما جرى اه هي
الروايه قائم على ردات الفعل الروايه
قائمه على فقط ان ان تحاول ازاحه ال اللوم
عن الجانب الحقيقي الذي اصدر هذا الامر
فبالتالي تاتي هذه الصور لتقول مره تذكر
العالم مره اخرى ان هذه الجريمه اولا لا
تسقط بالتقادم ثانيا عن الروايه التركيه
صحيحه ثالثا ان المساله القتل كانت مبيته
لم يات هكذا صدفه نتيجه الحيثيات التي جرت
في القنصليه
من واشنطن هل بالفعل هذه الصور يمكن ان
تكون قد ساهمت او ستسهم في القضيه حيه
بالنظر الى انه هنالك رهان واضح سواء كان
من عناصر داخل الاداره الامريكيه او من اه
الحكومه السعوديه على عامل الوقت اللي
تدخل هذه القضيه برمتها
منذ البدايه كنا نعلم ان تركيا تقدم كل
الانديه لدى وليها كل الادله وهذا ايضا مع
مجموعه مجموعه التسريبات التي عرضت الى
الاعلام لت بيبينوا بان هذه الروايه
اه لا لا يمكن التغطيه عليها وفي الواقع
قد تتعلق بالولايات المتحده فان في الشهر
الماضي منذ شهر تغير ال الكلام واذ الان
اصبح الناس مقتنعون بان هذه الجريمه
متعمده مخطط لها مسبقا
بمباركه من الحكومه السعوديه الفرق بين
الان وقبل شهر هو انه من جانب لدينا اه
كونغرس جديد سوف يبدا عمله و يسيطر عليه
الديمقراطيون الذين على الارجح سيطلقون
تحقيقا جديدا حول ما حصل والشيء الثاني
هون سيكون لدينا وزير دفاع الاخر جديد
وبالتالي الان يقدم اي مرشح لهذا المنصب
او لم يعين الشخص ولكن يقال بان وزير
الدفاع القادم يمكن يكون السنه الرها مش
لذكرى عامه الذي يلعب دورا كبيرا في نشر
اي حول
اغتيال شيء اذن هذا وقت مهم جدا واعتقد ان
هذه التسهيلات من الجانب التركي هو
التفكير للعالم بان هذه القضيه مازالت
قائمه وحيه وهل هذا تذكير دكتور حسن ستتبع
وتذكير ات اخرى انه يعني كان هنالك يمكن
القول ان هنالك فتره اه استراحه اه لوسائل
الاعلام جميع او للكونغرس اه بسبب انه
الكونغرس الجديد لم ينصب بعد وسط في يناير
هل هل هذا يعتبر موعد اخر من التذكير
بقضيه في رايك يعني تقريبا نعم انا اعتقد
ان التركيه تقوم ب تكتيك اه في غايه
الذكاء وهي تمهد المسرح من اجل ماذا س
يجري على الساحه الامريكيه لانه لانه نعرف
جميعا بان الذي يمتلك القرار في نهايه
الامر هو موقف الولايات
الامريكيه الذي يمكن ان يحدث الفرق اه
اولا في موقف الاداره الثانيه ايضا في
الطريقه التي سترد عليها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ونحن نعرف بان السعوديه ما زالت
تشكل الوقت وهي تراهن على ان الوقت سيمثل
العالم هذه القضيه الان نحن نعرف ان عدم
اه اه اه كيف سيكون هو رئيس الاستخبارات
نانسي بيلوسي على الارجح ستكون هي بمعنى
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي وهي توعدت
وتعهدت بانها ستفتح هذه التحقيقات اه وهي
تختلف مع رئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في كثير من الملفات ال يعني من ضمنها ايضا
حتى انسحاب من شرق الفرات
التوقيت يعني توقيت مقصود هذا التوقيت
مباشره اه يناير نحن في اخر يوم في الفين
وثمانيه اشهر
السلام طيب هذا التوقيت مقصود بتقدير نعم
ان تركيا هي تحاول ان تعد المسرح لمواجهه
لمواجهات قادمه على الساحه الامريكيه وهي
تعتقد تركيه محقه في ذلك اه ان ولي العهد
السعودي او المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ستاخذ بالحسبان
نتيجه التفاعلات التي ستجري على الساحه
الامريكيه من الان المكتوب يقرا من عنوانه
سيكون هناك يعني تحقيقات كثيره منها جلسات
استماع اه سيطلب اليها كبار موظفي الاداره
الامريكيه وسيفتح موضوعي على مصراعيه
السؤال ال ان الكونغرس لديه روايه بديله
لما يقدمه الرئيس وهي ورئيسه مجلس النواب
هي لا تتفق مع السياسه الخارجيه الصفقات
يه ان جاز التعبير للرئيس فبالتالي هنا
سيسال السؤال الصعب لماذا تصر على علاقه
مع ولي العهد هي تقول بان الولاء العلاقه
مع السعوديه في غايه الاهميه بالنسبه
للمصالح الامريكيه لكن ايضا اذا بقيت
السعوديه تحت هذه الاداره في اداره ولي
العهد فان ذلك سيشكل عبء على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فهي بالتالي انحاز الى
الاجندات الحقيقيه للدوله الامريكيه بدلا
من الاجندات الصفقات يه التي يروج لها
ستساعد سيساعد هذا الكشف عن هذه الصور
الجديده ل هذه المره ليست فقط حقائب او
اشخاص ينتقلون اه نحن نتحدث عن اكياس
بلاستيكيه سوداء ربما تحوي قطعا من هذه
الجهه اه كيف يمكن ان يتفائل ذلك في
الكونغرس الجديد في مجلس النواب الجديد
اعتقد انه من المهم ان نفهم ان
القياده السياسيه الامريكيه والسي اي اي
بشكل عام اه قد استلموا فعلا كل الادله
وبالتالي ما ينبغي طب ما يسمى يعرض الان
على الجمهور سبق ان تطلع عليه مساواه
المتقدمه من الحكومه الامريكيه واعتقد ان
التكتيك الحالي من جانب التركي هو محاوله
التاثير على الراي العام الامريكي لكي لا
يس هذه القضيه والشيء الثاني هو انه يكون
على العلاقات التركيه الامريكيه
تتحسن بشكل كبير الى حد ان الرئيس
قد تستلم الدعوه لزياره تركيا في في بدايه
عام الفين وتسعه عشر ويفترض بين الان وحتى
ذلك التاريخ
ستكون هناك بعض الاتصالات الدبلوماسيه
الاستعداد لهذه الزياره اما فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقه بين اردوغان وتراه فانها عندما
تتحسن فلذلك
المزيد من الضغوط على السعوديه يمكن تحاسب
المسؤولين عن هذه الجريمه وبالتالي اعتقد
ان هذا هو جزء من اللعبه الديبلوماسيه
الجاريه حاليا كما ان هناك الجانب الثاني
من هذا الموضوع الا وهو العلاقه جانب
العلاقات العامه اي ابقاء الراي العام او
على وعي ومتابعه لهذا الموضوع وعرض المزيد
من التفاصيل عليه بحيث ان الكونغرس جديد
سيواصل بذل الضغوط على اه البيت الابيض
وعلى الرئيس الان بالذات شكرا جزيلا السيد
سجود ان يبرر البحث في شؤون الخليج من
واشنطن فاصل قصير مشاهدينا نتابع بعده كيف
ستتعامل المواقف الدوليه مع هذه المعطيات
الجديده التي كشفتها الصور بشان قضيه في
ظل الاصوات الداعيه لتحقيق العداله فيها
ان تقوم عنها
[موسيقى]
ام
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه من برنامج
بلا حدود ناقشوا الصور الجديده التي ظهرت
اه اللي اه ما يعتقد انها قطع من داخل
القنصليه السعوديه البيت القنصل السعودي
في اكياس اه اعود الى ضيفي في الاستوديو
الدكتور حسن البراري الكشف عن هذه الصور
هل يصلح في حد ذاته اه دليلا وردا على
حديث الصفقه ان هناك صفقه ما بين
تركيا وبين السعوديه وبين واشنطن في قضيه
اه بدليل ويدللون بانه كان هنالك صمت لمده
طويله طوال الاسابيع الماضيه يعني اول ان
لم يكن هناك صمتا طويلا طوال المده
السابقه الاعلام الامريكي كان يعني عمل
وفقا لما يتوفر اه استجد من احداث وتوفر
المعلومات اه يعني وخاصه ايضا ليس فقط
الاعلام الامريكي ايضا مراكز التفكير في
الولايات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهي تنتقد ليلى
عن اي مجال يعني انه انه كان هنالك صامته
في تركيا يعني لم تكن ملكه معلومات جديده
وتسريبات جديده بشان هذه القضيه باستثناء
التصريحات التي تظهر في المؤتمرات الصحفيه
اننا مستمرون
انا في تقديري ان
تركيا ربما اعطت كل ما لديها وقد ابدت
القضيه حيه لكن تركيه الان تعرف باننا
ندخل عاما جديدا وان العام الجديد سيكون
هناك مجلس النواب في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بنيويه مختلف اه والشخصيات التي
ستسيطر على هذه اللجان هي شخصيات يعني
تتوعد بان هذه القضيه لن لن تغلق مره
وللابد فبالتالي ياتي ربما في سياقه
التفكير وفي سياق ايضا يعني صب الزيت على
النار باعتبار ان تركيا تريد ان تبقى هذه
القضيه مفتوحه ثانيا اه يعني في الاسبوع
الماضي كان يتحدث وزير الخارجيه التركي عن
تدويل القضيه واحتمال التدوير الان يعني
كل المعلومات تقريبا مكتب الان هنالك
معلومات ناقصه لكي تبدو خطوات التدويل هي
بدات فعليا بخطوات التدويل يعني
التي ال الحديث عن التدويل هو ياتي ايضا
في سياق تفكير الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بانه وان كان القرار الامريكي في النهايه
لان هناك في محافل اخرى يمكن اثاره هذه
القضيه وتشكل بدورها ضغطا جديدا على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على الرئيس
بتحديد الذي يواجه ضغوطا داخليه اه
فبالتالي ال القضيه انا بتقديري ان
التركيه السياسه التركيه القائمه على
التكتيك وال والتوقيت الذي يناسبها فهي
ربما لو اراد الصفقه في هذه القضيه لا
توصلت الى صفقه منذ فتره يعني طويله لكنها
لا تريد ان تصل الى صفقه على حساب مساله
العداله وهي ترى ايضا في ولي العهد
السعودي على الاقل يفكر الاتراك بانه شديد
ل ل اجندات التركيه في هذه المنطقه لان
السعوديه تتخوف تتوجس من تركيا وتتهمها
باتهامات كثيره جدا فبالتالي اردوغان من
مصلحته ايضا ان ان يتخلص من هذا السلوك
بمعنى ان ان اردوغان يريد ان يدخل سلوك
التغيير في سلوك النظام السعودي وليس
تغييرا في النظام السعودي يعني هذه القضيه
ربما يعني ينبغي ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
طيب اه دكتور سيد اه
اه اذن ليست هنالك كما يقول ضيفنا لكن
هنالك نيه واضحه ل لتدويل من جانب تركيا
اه هل بعد هذه المعلومات ومع اه تنصيب
الكونغرس الجديد اه يمكن ان يكون لتدويل
حظ من النقاش الجدي في الاداره الامريكيه
اعتقد ان احدى الاول الخطوات التي ستشهدها
ما ان يبدا الكونغرس الجديد عملها اه هي
اننا سنرى السعوديه ستحاول
ان اه
ان تعتقل بعض هؤلاء او تحاسب الثمانيه عشر
شخصا المتهم الذين وضعوا في قائمه
العقوبات الامريكيه
كان سيء وجهها الى سابقه يعني او ال ال ال
العسيري العسيري للهواء المستشارين
الرئيسيين كبيرين حالتهما من قبل وليد لكن
ذلك
اضافه اسمها الى قائمه العقوبات
لهؤلاء شخصين
هل سيواجهون العداله علينا ان ننتظر ونرى
ذلك لكن الجانب السعودي بعض الضباط
المستوى الادنى سيقدم العداله اولا زياده
الضغوط على السعوديه فرغم الجنرال عسيري و
اه والشيء القحطاني ربما ايضا
يحصل لها وتشمل هما عقوبه بطريقه ذكيه من
السلطات السعوديه
عذرا للمقاطعه سيد يعني هذه هذه الشخصيات
اه يعني اي اي عداله هل هي العداله
السعوديه اه وهل هذه الشخصيات لا لا نفترض
ان نستعد يها قررت غدا ان هؤلاء هم
المسلمون الوحيدون واعدمتهم على سبيل
المثال هل هناك حققت العداله ماذا عن قرار
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي الذي صدر بالاجماع
ان المسؤول الاول هو محمد بن سلمان
من الواضح ان محمد بن سلمان
واوضح موقفه بشكل لا لبس فيه واعتقد ان ما
سيحصل وان محمد الاستاذ ما سيحاول ان يلقي
اللوم على الضباب من مستوى منخفض
وهذا الت سيكون
الاخرون لكن هذا ما اتوقع ان او توقعا نحن
من ال السلطات السعوديه
هذا المتوقع من المتوقع من السلطات
الامريكيه ا ما المتوقع من الاداره
الامريكيه من الكونغرس من مجلس الشيوخ
ومجلس النواب
ما يمكن ان نتوقعه من ال مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي واضح جدا وهو ال الاصرار على
العلاقات الاعتياديه وتعمل طريق لن يستمر
اي ان سياسات السعوديه اه قد ثبت انها
تقلب استقرار المنطقه وخاصه حضرها في
اليمن وبالتالي تعدد الولايات المتحده
مستعده لدعم مثل هذه السياسه
وبالتالي هذا ال هذا سيتغير وفيما يتعلق ب
محمد بن سلمان فاعتقد على الارجح ان
السلطات السعوديه ربما قاموا ب بعض
الاقتراحات والاتفاقات مع
الامريكان حول هذا الموضوع ارباح تقدموا
التهديدات هدد البيت الابيض
تهديدات بالضبط ولكنها على الاقل رجع
نقلت عن طريق القنوات الدبلوماسيه
الثنائيه لكن وجهه نظر لا يمكن التحديد
المتحده استقرار المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مهم للغايه وان الخطوه الاولى ستكون
التاكد من ان سياساتها التخلي باستقرار
منطقه تتغير لتصبح اكثر بناءه لحل هذا
سيتحرك لا اعرف ولكن اه الحل لكن هكذا
ستفكر في الكونغرس القادم الجديد
وهل هذا ايضا هو تفكير اردوغان وتركيا
الدكتور حسن البراري وانتقد ذكرتها سابقا
انه المطلوب هو تغيير في الاسلوب وليس
وليس تغيير في النظام يعني هو ليس المطلوب
تغيير النظام السعودي يعني لا لا احد
يتحدث عن تغيير العائله المالكه مثلا اه
لكن وجود محمد بن سلمان على على سده
الحكومه خاصه بعد التغييرات الجديده التي
قام بها وهو جلب يعني شخصيات هي قريبه جدا
من هو وكانه لم يتعلم من هذه الازمه فهذا
شيء يخيف الامريكان واثنين الافراد
بالمناسبه لانه بالسعوديه الدوله قويه ذات
مكانه عاليه بهذه الامكانات وبهذا السلوك
هي تشكل خطرا على تركيا و تشكل خطرا على
الاستقرار الاقليمي و تشكل خطرا على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وربما يختلف
مع ضيفه في واشنطن فيما يتعلق بال
بالكونغرس الكونغرس عندما نتحدث عن اجماع
مائه مائه عضو بالمجلس الشيوخ يقولون بان
المسؤول هو محمد بن سلمان هذا يعني عمليه
بانه يجب ان ان يعاقب يجب ان تكون هناك
مساله واحده من الاشياء التي لابد ان
يقوموا فيه هو اه اه يعني على الاقل
مقايضه لابقاء ه كما كان مع تغيير سلوك حل
المشكله مع قطر انهاء الحرب في اليمن اه
وايضا ال البدء في ان تكون السعوديه دوله
ذات اه اه يعني اثر ايجابي في هذه المنطقه
بدل ان تكون دوله ذات اثر تدميري عندما
يقول ان زكريا وهو وهو مرشح لان يكون وزير
الدفاع يقول بان محمد بن سلمان القوه
الامنيه في هذه المنطقه هو لن ياتي ويخضع
الاتهام هو سياتي هو يختلف هو ينتمي الى
محور الراشدين الاكسده اللي الذي تم ايضا
ها فيهم بواشنطن الان اذا جاء اه اه ليست
يعني الامه فبالتالي عليه ان ان يقود
وزاره الدفاع البنتاغون والجيش الامريكي
مع السعوديه وفقا لل اجندات الامريكيه على
محمد سلمان عليه ان القوه داخل او الملك
سلمان على التوجيه القوى هذه الامور س
يطلبها الاتراك سيطلبها ايضا المجتمع
الدولي سيطل بها الاداره الامريكيه
الجديده بعد ان اه اه تبدا مرحله الجلسات
الاجتماع في الكونغرس القضيه لن تبقى هكذا
وكان محمد بن سلمان بالنهايه نفذ من من
المسؤوليه البلدان في عند الكونغرس
الامريكي ومدان عند الاتراك ومدان عند
المجتمع الدولي ما ينفعه الان هو ان
السعوديه دوله في غايه الاهميه بالنسبه
الاستقرار الاقليميه لكن النتيجه التي
يتوصل الى المجتمع الدولي بان هذه الدوله
تحت قيادته ستكون عامل زعزعه استقرار يجب
ان يكون هناك ضغط لهذه الدوله وتغيير في
هذا السلوك لا يمكن ان يتم تغيير هذا
السلوك اذا بقي المسلمين او اذا بقي بهذه
القوه الكبيره وهذا التركيز الشديد في
القوه الولايات المتحده سبق وان حاصرت
انظمه سنين طويله ضيفي في واشنطن
اه بهدف اسقاطها وعزلها ولكن لم يحدث هذا
اه
عندك النظام الايراني عندك النظام الكوري
الشمالي عند كل نظام صدام حسين اه لم يسقط
الا بالقوه وهذا غير مستبعد طبعا فيه في
حال في الحاله التي نتحدث عنها ما الذي
بيد الولايات المتحده اي تغيير سلوك
السعوديه اه في هذه القضيه تحديدا
اعتقد انها فعلا غير
السعوديه فمن المهم ان نتذكر انه الان بعد
ان بدات محادثات السلام بين الحوثيين او
الحكومه اليمنيه هذه التنازلات لم تتحقق
الا بعد ان قامت سياسيه اي اي بالاستنتاج
بان ال ال ال ولي العهد سلمان حملتهم الذي
نظمه وامر بهذا القتل اذن هذا هو اول
نتيجه اولا والتنازل شهدناه من السعوديه
ثم هناك مساله اه اه في اليمن لابد تحصل
ايضا تنازلات
ولكن هناك محفزات السعوديه لتغيير سوى من
قبل الرئيس او ال او الكونغرس لتقديمه
باستمرار في تقديم الدعم
لهذه الحرب الكارثيه على الصعيد الانساني
وطبعا زملائه والسياسه الخارجيه هنا
نتذكر الازمه في السعوديه وكندا ونتذكر مع
اصابه وزير رئيس الوزراء اللبناني وايضا
الحمله ضد قطر كل هذه القضايا وهذه هي
السياسات
مدمره كانت من قبل السعوديه لاستقرار
المنطقه والولايات المتحده تمنى تنتهي
ينتهي ذلك
ولو ان محمد سليمان استطاعوا اراد ان يقوم
بمثل هذه التنازلات فاعتقد
لذلك شكرا جزيلا اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
الباحث في شؤون الخليج والشرق الاوسط من
واشنطن اشكر ضيفي في الاستوديو الدكتور
حسن البراري استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
الجامعه الاردنيه لا يتعدى الحلقه في امان
الله
[موسيقى]